Margaret Alexander didn't fully realize
what she was up against when her mother
first began to exhibit symptoms of
Alzheimer's disease even though she had
seen similar symptoms in her aunts they
had the same kind of symptoms they would
forget they would get confused
disoriented and repeat just like mom now
a member of the family is always with
the 96 year old the one time that causes
the greatest concern is when she walked
out of the apartment at night in her
nightgown it was a rapid decline for a
woman who had raised two children been
active in her church and worked outside
the home a factor now known to help
stave off memory loss one new study
shows the average memory performance for
non-working women between 60 and 70
years old declined twice as fast as
women who were working outside the home
two thirds of people living with
Alzheimer's in the United States are
women experts used to attribute that to
the fact that women tend to live longer
than men do but new evidence suggests
that's not the entire story and in fact
women's brains are different the latest
research on the subject presented by the
Alzheimer's Association shows that women
with the disease have higher levels of
brain metabolism compared with men which
may account for their superior verbal
memory performance what they found was
that the tau protein is much more likely
to accumulate in these areas in women
and this is important because this area
is really prone to spreading the disease
though a protein related to the disease
tends to spread more quickly
contributing to what appears to be a
faster decline in women there is an
impact on detection knowing that the
disease can present differently and
progressed differently in men and women
the medical community doctors need to
recognize that and maybe be more
sensitive to the differences between how
women present with early disease versus
men it's useful information for families
too but it's reassuring to have the
information because without the
information you don't know what to do as
those with a parent or sibling with
Alzheimer's
Oh see I gotta are themselves more
likely to develop the disease
Kristen salumi al-jazeera